what is your feeling about
um not anyone in particular of course
but what's your feeling about
uh s-pacs and cryptos and
so i i you know our panicking four
models in euphoric territory it measures
sentiment
and i think some of the stuff you've
seen around meme stocks around this
packs
around um crypto is just lots of
liquidity sloshing around looking for a
place to go
and a gen in again in this kind of
environment speculative activity can
occur
it's not that look specs themselves are
not inherently bad
they've been around for a long time
right and the idea of giving smart
people money to invest in businesses is
dedicated to turn around
or grow faster because they're good they
have good management skills is all fine
it's when you have over 400 of them
hitting the market
stars and supports legends
a lot of the celebrities packs are kind
of an interesting dynamic
um you know
they amused me more than anything else
um you know people buy it
oh i got to you know i got to hang out
with so and so yeah
um i get to hang out with danielle so
it's it's all good
but the the but i think that the notion
of
money going to areas that probably they
shouldn't go into because they don't
really understand
them is worrisome okay and
you know i'm asked a lot about this
stuff i have a 94 year old father who
loves to invest
and um he always asks me questions about
some of these things and and i
know no matter how much i try to deter
him from doing
these things um he does some of these
things he's 94. yeah it's funny
this is fun uh and thank god his brain's
functioning and his body functions well
and he's you know we should all have his
health
in 94. but um but but but i worry about
again he's these are areas he's totally
inexperienced about
and is willing to kind of risk some
stuff and like i told him dad
just don't do it he goes why and i think
because i'd like to have an inheritance
you know
whatever when you go and um
tell me how you really feel i know he
laughs he gets he gets the joke
um but it it's you know
i to me it's just a reflection of the
sentiment
i'm looking for my get-rich-quick scheme
yeah i i have a lot of people on my
twitter feed who call me a boomer which
i'm not
hey boomer hey boomer hey boomer don't
you know you don't need to work i mean
this
is common common um
that's right that's why i enjoy
listening my children complain about
if i understand how much diapers cost
and how much the
kids clothes costs because they grow out
in about four minutes and you know we're
working and we
were trying to keep up that and it's
like killing us and they're smiling
what's so funny
i said maybe you'll appreciate your
parents for once um
you know but but you know they they do
learn it as like
you know it's it's when you're 20 you
want to live in manhattan
because you want to go party and order
chinese food at three in the morning
and when you have kids at three in the
morning all you want is those kids to
sleep
and not be woken up by the uh you know
the the fire truck going down the street
at the police car he went inside a
garbage truck going down the street
mom and dad weren't idiots living in
suburbia and guess where my kids live
now
suburbia because they want their kids to
sleep yeah no i mean i can't tell you
how many
friends in the city who haven't been in
the city you know you just get older and
you
more wiser and more experienced you know
there's something to that i was watching
a bill maher
thing about um you know that when people
hey boomer and all things
like people if you learn something new
every day and you've lived
ten thousand more days than the other
person
probably there's some wisdom there there
and he
i think he did this whole thing on 18th
34 year olds is the you know the prime
advertising
cohort he says you know why because
they're the most gullible people on the
planet
i kind of enjoyed that it's like bill
bill's making a lot more sense to me
almost every day
[Music]
you